you've got Wow
this place is amazing why's a buzz gonna
meet us here he must be held up
somewhere hey up here Astro Boy if you
think you can take our top prize spots
your room dead wrong help me get out of
here
[Music]
[Music]
of angel hair and ice-cream castle
[Music]
and everywhere
I put the cards up where
but now
we block the Sun hey Rayna
everyone so
good
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I really don't know
[Music]
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you're kidding me he said that to your
face to my face and then what happens I
get real close right I'm like I don't
care which Cabbage Patch you're from oh
give me back my viewmaster before I
knock the dimples off your face you are
I don't care bear yeah you see the new
movie trailer for what you ain't see it
see what what is it duckie what they're
making another Toy Story movie I thought
those movies were gone dog they made
three movies didn't make three movies
this is number four toy stories - yeah
what about Buzz Lightyear stuff I am
Buzz Lightyear Space Ranger what is like
to infinity and your mom that's not
right you sure no that's not right
pretty sure that's it let me show you to
insanity and blonde what are you even
saying immunity and hey guys you got it
all wrong it's to infinity and beyond
nothing about science
[Music]